[Music]
homie look what I become
podcast is late so I'm fired up yeah
okay we never do podcasts this late uh
folks episode number 184 uh with the
founder of Papa John's Pizza uh Papa
John Schnatter is in the house here with
us it's great to have you on the podcast
thank you Patrick thank you Adam yes
it's it's uh we got we got a special
project we're going to be doing today we
have a lot of things to cover with you
guys today uh one of the things I asked
them if he'd be open to and I literally
we just told him a few minutes ago I
said would you open open to this idea of
uh we in a minute probably in about 30
minutes so stick around we're gonna
order pizza from four places local
different names all big names including
Papa John
and we're going to order the works and
we're going to order the pepperoni I
believe it's what we're going to be
doing okay and we're going to time to
see who shows up the fastest and at the
same time we're gonna have take a bite
or the look what it looks like and we'll
have it on the camera you'll be able to
judge it a person that's been in this
you were a founder of Papa John it's not
like you're got hired or you're still
you're the founder and you're going to
give your feedback on and how is Papa
John gonna do a blind taste test and see
what he thinks I think we throw a little
mask on you tell us what the best is can
you recognize I feel like we can have
some fun we're gonna do this and about a
half hour I'm thinking about 30 minutes
or so stick around guys yeah definitely
stick around and then we got a lot of
things to cover obviously the the
controversial story with you I want the
audience to hear about it on what
happened when on the recording with the
laundry the the marketing agency all
that stuff on how that happened where
you're everywhere every time we turn on
the TV you're looking at an ad you're
watching NFL you're everywhere Montana
manic you are literally everywhere to
all of a sudden boom yeah after what
happened with you know Colin Kaepernick
and annealing in the commentary on a
recording that came out and
story afterwards where not a lot of
people have seen the story afterwards
what happened with the recording of the
agency came back out and you know that's
the part that I think it's good for them
to know as well and then look the
reality of it is you know you can love
them or hate him he went from zero to
being a billionaire and he had a Camaro
which he sold when he was younger to
support his dad's business
and eventually years later he went and
found the person that he sold the Camaro
to who had already sold it and they
eventually found somebody that had the
Camaro I think you bought the Camaro for
twenty five thousand dollars and the
person you sold the Camaro to to help
you find the person you gave them twenty
five thousand dollars and you made it a
Camaro day and everybody that drove a
Camaro got free pizza for the day or
something like that I heard it was 250
000. yeah 250 000 to the guy he bought
it right twenty five thousand to the
finder's fee found the other one yeah
exactly
Papa John in the house let's go all
right so uh for folks that don't know if
you don't mind take a quick minute and
give your background on upbringing how
Papa John's got started and how it ended
up turning into a multi-billion dollar
company
well I think my two really Heroes were
my dad and my grandfather uh my dad was
a zero entrepreneur had probably 9 or 10
11 businesses and every single one
failed so we had these bankruptcies
these Financial issues all around the
house and my grandfather who was more
conservative he had three businesses in
the law firm and they all prospered and
so how blessed was I to have the
dichotomy of being in a family that's
literally broke a year behind on the
house payments turn off electricity turn
off the gas to over here where
everything's paid for and it's safe and
it's prosperous and he gets a new
Cadillac and a new car and a new house
so it was that dichotomy that take the
risk you know you gotta if you're an
entrepreneur which I am by Spirit take
the risk but if you make that risk you
take that bet you better make it good
like so so so you saw them uh on 11
businesses with your dad as well as your
grandpa at what point did you say like
my dad built 11 constantly struggling
didn't happen you know maybe I don't
want to start a business maybe I should
just go be a safer job maybe I should go
do completely so maybe I'm going to be a
salesperson what made you say even
though you saw all the struggles with
your dad I'm still going to start a
business I didn't know
um I had a grass cutting business when I
was eight nine years old I had a painted
gutter was when I was 11 or 12 a little
paint company that my grandfather and I
started
um worked through high school work
through college uh had Central solar
help with my dad various companies but
really didn't know I was an entrepreneur
and I got back from graduating college
at Ball State and I couldn't find a job
and my father had a bar that was
bankrupt 57 beer joint mixed Lounge
rough bikers fights every night
everybody's drunk legit legit you're
gonna get a fight everybody this is is
in Indiana you know where you grew up
Indiana 1983. he's going bankrupt he's
64 000 in debt selling 50 Cent beers
want to know if I'd come in and help him
and we're not 10 days into this thing
and I said dad I don't think uh he
thought he was ten thousand dollars in
debt I don't think you're 10 Grandad I
think you're 20 25 now it ended up being
64. and he said well
um and you were 16 at this time I'm
83 I'm 21.
um and I said no dad I think I can do
this and he said there's no way just he
was an attorney he was prosecutor
youngest City judge please just help my
reputation do what you can do and just
let the thing wonder and I said no dad I
think I can really do this I can fix
this now that was 10 days in it just was
like
um I made good grades in school
pretty good athlete but I worked harder
than other kids I mean I always had to
do things a little this running the
business was like falling out of this
chair it was the most natural make the
beer cold have good people serving it
smile clean the place up make sure the
mcburger is hot and have a pool
tournament on Sunday a euchre tournament
on Tuesday Little Kings on Thursday but
it was the most intuitive things and
we're 64 000 in bankruptcy
Labor Day weekend of 83 I sell the car
for 2 800 in October of 83. we paid off
thirty two thousand dollars by January
1st of eighty four and Clark County
State Bank loaned me the other 32 Grand
in less than four months we went from
bankruptcy to solvent wow yeah it was
just a it was just it was my gift to
give you confidence that gave you a
little bit of confidence where maybe I
can operate a business I was confident
okay got it so your struggle wasn't
being confident
um it was when I went in okay it was
before I went in but after I went in it
was like okay I can run a business and
your dad just couldn't figure it out but
you could at 21. and he was a grown man
judge lawyer and he just couldn't
operate a business but you came in at 21
Hotshot and figured it out how did that
work
yeah Dad was just he was happy-go-lucky
he loved the racetrack
he believed in absentee ownership he
thought the thing would run itself
whereas Papaw was save every nickel you
know a penny saved as a penny earned you
have to be there you have to tend to the
shop but entrepreneurship runs on all
four sides of the grandparents all four
so entrepreneurship was in the blood I
just didn't know it that was your
original question when did you did you
know it I didn't until I got thrown in
the the Lion's Den in a pork chop suit
and survived I love it so you pay it you
help now you're solvent at what point do
you leave and say I'm going to go do it
on my own
we're December January 83 84. and
um my dad had a joke
um John gets him drunk at night and I
get him divorced in the morning because
he was attorney I hated we were good
great business model
yeah
I hated the bar business I hated the
drinking the smoking the fights
um you're really doing something that's
negative impact on human beings which is
part of my soul that I just totally
disagree with
and I had this idea for a pizza place
when I was up in Muncie Indiana because
I'd made pizzas at Rocky's subhub and
also made pizzas under Chris
cameramasini the Greek at greets
Pizzeria so I had all the recipes and
the design of the place and the logo and
um I think it was March February March I
go I know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
bust that uh broom closet down that wall
and I'm gonna put me some news to
restaurant equipment in there and I'm
gonna take that box with the recipes and
the logo and we're going to do five
dollar pizzas out the back and 50 Cent
beers out the front with a 50 Cent game
of pool that was our business model
for five bucks pizza 50 Cent beer and 50
Cent game of pool game of pool and and
we got we got the pool tables up to a
thousand a week I used to go in the bank
where they had a machine a thousand
dollars uh that's two thousand games and
quarters and quarters in each hand the
girl the girl behind the counter the
banks teller was kind of cute and I'd
walk in with them
and uh sounds like how ridicula would
pay me in quarters we were doing
anything and then we're doing three
grand a week in pizza sales in the broom
closet and we're doing seven thousand
weeks on 50 Cent beers we're knocking
down 124 000 a year selling five dollar
pizza and 50 Cent game of pool and 50
Cent beers in 1984. wow so so at this
point have you made pizza before was
this is not done that's all I've done I
made pizzas when I was because we were
talking outside is
um I was a dishwasher Rockies uh 235 an
hour uh 1977 78. that was minimum wage
um and I hated washing dishes and right
across from my wash dishes where Joe
fondrice made pizzas and the fondrice
brothers Joe John and Frank ran Rocky
subpop and I always dreamed you know
getting uh promoted from washing dishes
to making pizza and they got it right up
in the Saturday scene in Louisville uh
Joe fondrice went to the front of the
house to host us and John Snyder Papa
John got promoted for more dishes to
make him pizza and I fell in love with
it I loved everything about it so how
much different was the pizza that you
were learning from them versus how you
adjusted it to your style
what I did is I run around and stole
everybody's best ideas okay I went to
gaddy's
um they did some things with with the
cheese uh Chris caramessini uh the Greek
he had a little Sweetness in the sauce a
little sugar that I wanted to increase
the acid sugar ratio with our Vine
ripened Tomatoes at Papa John's to make
a little sweeter nothing I learned at uh
Greeks we do 8 000 a week in pizza sales
and Rockies we do 8 000 a day at Greeks
because it was college so Greeks taught
me the sauce and the processes for high
volume they had a bakery in town cross
Bakery we used to study what they did
with the crust
um Domino's went over and took a lot of
their systems away from us deployed
Domino so we just went around everywhere
I was a flipped hamburgers at Wendy's in
1980 so we we just went around and stole
everybody's best out what'd you learn
from Domino's and Wendy's would you pick
up from them Domino's systems are and
were incredible they just had a process
is where the efficiency of getting that
order getting them made getting the oven
and getting out the door we're Second To
None what was the second Wendy Wendy's
what I learned in Wendy's I don't like
Grease
the grease coming off of those
hamburgers gets in your face and your
hair you go you go work at a Wendy's
old-fashioned hamburger and you'll kiss
the kitchen floor of a pizza joint a
pizza a Papa John's because the flowers
who cares about flower but grease so um
what I learned from our David who
learned from Colonel Sanders was quality
um you know quality is our recipe and we
used to Patty the beef in the back of
the store and uh our David Thomas was a
fanatic about quality and um you know we
had him speak a couple times at our
convention uh he was a really uh he was
simple guy wasn't um you know wouldn't
been wasn't a big talker wasn't didn't
use big words but you always knew where
he stood with him and of course Colonel
Sanders is 15 miles down the road from
where I grew up up all these guys early
on Jim Patterson Sanders did you meet
with all of them at that time I didn't
meet the colonel I met Patterson got him
of course Ken Taylor with Roadhouse Jim
Patterson who had the story who had the
most impressive personality like who did
you meet and say this is an impressive
person here
in the food business in the food
business yeah Patterson Patterson did
the only one of any of us that's done
multiple Patterson did Long John
Silver's he did Wendy's he did chichis
he did Rally's Hamburgers he did
Fuddruckers he's the only one of us that
really Ken Taylor you could say who just
passed away this past year with Texas
Roadhouse he did Bubba's and Jaggers he
did a couple well they haven't really
growned anything big yet but I mean
Colonel Sanders was kind of um you know
chicken our David Thomas was a
franchisee for KFC and then became
Wendy's and then of course the only
thing I've done is is Papa John's and a
few other things the bar but Patterson
was the one guy that was
multi-faceted in his ability to do more
than one concept you know what Dave
Thomas the the late Dave Thomas and Ray
Kroc lived in the same Community here in
Fort Lauderdale did I know that yeah
before they passed away both of them
lived here great I'm glad you Croc's my
hero yeah behind the Arches John love
great great book Crocs the guy that
figured it out if that franchisee
doesn't make money then the mother ship
is worthless I mean he looked at
everything from a a franchisee
perspective he used to charge the
um the franchisees like a half percent
royalty wouldn't even cover his overhead
on supervising it and it wasn't until
Harry stubborn came along in uh I think
late 70s in the 80s and came up with a
real estate play where we'll you know
we'll buy the land build the building
take ten percent he was the business guy
Harry stubborn was the guy that figured
out the economics but Ray was a
salesperson he was the visioner he was
the guy that said we can turn this into
something big
he was a multi-mixer he was a milkshake
blender salesman for God's sake when he
met saying Ray Kroc you must have loved
that movie the founder with Michael
Keaton I mean that you how many times
have you seen that movie I've seen it
um um a couple times I don't think it
really Embraces what Croc was all about
um his his I mean he lost all his
friends at his country club because they
wouldn't live up to his qscnv he was
fanatical about quality service the
cleanliness and value
um in a character you know I mean he
liked to have a good time but Croc
um his I mean remember Croc McDonald's
what fit 1955 1960 Hell Burger Chef had
been around 20 30 years White Castle
been around 20 30 40 years a Burger King
Burger Queen all these Concepts were way
before McDonald's and yeah he came 20 30
40 years check uh check my mom he came
out before
Burger Chef did so yeah but but Checkers
say McDonald's wasn't the OG that we
think it is as today we think that's the
original McDonald's you know a hamburger
joint yeah but he by the way he's right
Burger King came out before McDonald's
wow I didn't even know that did you know
that no I hadn't had no idea McDonald's
was late to the party and Croc still
kicked all their I love that yeah what
kind of relate to that do you kind of
relate to the fact that you know Pizza a
lot of these guys have been around for a
while and you came out and well the
thing we're most proud of is our team
you know our people in our product and
our team
um but remember in our category there's
some forty thousand independent
pizzerias so you when I came along you
had Domino's Little Caesars and pizza
you had the three three big players now
all 40 000 independent pizzerias are
wired like us they they want to get they
want to be John they want to get through
that window of opportunity and out of
the 40 000 we've been the only one that
can come out of that horse racing and
get to the top four we did it and that's
just because the great team effort and
great product and I got to tell you we
leaned on the book um behind the Arches
by John love pretty hard did you did you
ever meet Ray or no no I've been up to
Oakbrook
third University
um they go through the museum I mean
that the office up there has actually
has a McDonald's in it with a pub
because he liked to drink beer after the
day was over but you know
um your quality is only as good as your
consistency
very systematic guy everything was about
system with that everything and I don't
know when it was one time McDonald's
tested out creating a pineapple Burger I
don't know if you remember that story
yeah so he said one guy came out and
said let's sell a pineapple Burger you
know how long it lasted like apparently
lasted like a couple days people hated
it yeah it's probably not a good idea so
they would test some of the products it
would come out and then boom Ray one
time said 90 percent of the best ideas
that we got at McDonald's came from
bottom up would you would you agree with
that like was that also cultural with
you guys were a lot of your operators
would say hey John what if we do this
and what if we test this and what if we
do that
well I I think you always got to look
for new and better ways the McRib
sandwich was a franchisee idea the Egg
McMuffin was a franchisee of McDonald's
um but I'm sure forever one or two great
ideas they may probably have a thousand
bad
but when you start running your business
from the c-suite and you're not out in
with the franchisee store level
um
the suppliers if you're not out looking
on what's going on in the real world and
learning then you're not going to
innovate and get better the first you
all just ordered some pizzas from Jets
and Papa John's when I walked in and the
driver of Papa John's hadn't busted me
yet and I asked the guy I said hey is
the pizza any good Papa John's go no not
really and I was like floored he has no
clue who you are yet no he well he did
after about three or four minutes
can you imagine how fun that's hilarious
yeah I go really he goes yeah it's not
too good I said do you eat Eagles I
don't eat it but I'm like you know three
or four years ago a driver would have
never set our product is something he
wouldn't Pride home a driver's seat
driver Papa John's just told me in the
lobby says you know it's not very good
pizza so I got to tell you this so for
me here's my papa here's my Papa John's
experience are you a pizza guy or like
do you have one that you order like by
the way if you're listening to this just
out of curiosity What's Your Pizza like
if you're gonna watch a game on Sunday
if you're gonna order pizza for your
kids or yourself or your family what are
you ordering what's your number one
place you go go to what's yours I mean I
don't want to go too long on this story
I had a pizza place in South Beach
called Pizza Rustica and when I was
going in my Heyday and partying and
nightlife in South Beach with Keith I
would go out I was I had no money to my
name I would go out I had five dollars
in my pocket and I would go out and
party in South Beach I knew all the the
bartenders and the owners and the clubs
and the promoters I would go out and you
know you're gonna shock you get wasted
for free have fun great times at South
Beach I'd spend five dollars at the end
of the night uh on a slice of pizza and
then uh I ballooned up to about 235
pounds the biggest I've ever been yeah I
burnt them all but if anybody is a
friend of Adam you have those pictures
DM me right now I'm gonna share it with
the audience
anybody the worst one 235 is what we're
looking for not 232. no anyone let me
tell you my Papa John's story so here's
what happened with me so I'm in the Army
we lived in Van Nuys down the street
from base it uh uh a little Caesar so I
was a Little Caesars guy in the 90s so
if I'm in the Van Nuys with my Dad hey
Dad let's order some literacies we go
down the street pick it up and boom we
come back five dollar hot and ready and
they had the Little Caesars what was the
bread that's something that was a crazy
bread the crazy bread yeah it was great
anyway so I go into the army and I'm in
South Carolina okay and then we go to uh
uh Fort Campbell Kentucky I'm in Fort
Campbell Kentucky so guys let's order
pizza so yeah
is that a local place no Everybody Eats
Papa John's I've never heard of Papa
John's so we're talking about I'm in
California I've never heard of Papa
John's he says dude it's the best pizza
I said Papa John's yeah I'm not ordering
Papa John's what's is there Little
Caesars dude just try Papa John's so
they bring Papa John's
this is September of 97. you remember
the day I can tell you this because it's
still like when you go boot camp and AIT
for six months and you don't eat pizza
the first time you eat pizza it's like a
16 year old boy for his first time
experiences you know the magic of you
know what you call some crazy bread
crumbs some crazy bread yeah so anyway
so I eat this Papa John's Pizza but what
what got me hooked wasn't the pizza John
when I dipped that pizza into that
garlic
sauce that you have came over for me I
said this is since September of 97 till
today Dylan will tell you you asked you
call my family right and ask what's
Daddy's pizza that's a Papa John's just
because of that sauce from September
1997. whose idea was a garlic sauce
well the two little add-ons we give to
the consumer uh to say thanks or the
pepperoncini and and the garlic sauce
yeah pepperoncinis came from the
fondrissey brothers at Rockies and
um that was just a nice little touch
they did they did the garlic sauce came
from a local independent pizzeria in New
Albany which was Two Towns over
and the problem with that garlic sauce
is that it makes allowance next to the
broom closet operation we can mount that
we could melt that margarine put the
salt and the garlic in there fill up
these little cups and then put it out
with every pizza because we're only
selling you know five six pizzas a day
well we started getting busier
and this garlic sauce issues a real
problem because the garlic sauce is
getting everywhere
and
um we couldn't figure out how to pour it
in so we went down to the local funeral
home because that garlic sauce will eat
through rubber hoses we used to get the
holes from Hoosier Hardware
hello Mama shop a hardware shop in in
downtown Jeff on Spring went to Coots
Funeral Home in the
fluid that you get out of the body that
won't that garlic sauce won't tear that
tube up so we put a five gallon bucket
up there with that tube that they use
for dead bodies and we'd fill up these
garlic sauces and we line all the cups
up well that worked until we got up to
you know 30 40 pizza today and then that
sauce was going in everywhere and so
store number three we got rid of the
garlic sauce we said that's it we don't
want to do it it's too big of a mess
plus it's expensive customers raised
cane they went up they got they went
good people and so we had to put them
back in yeah
um that garlic I figured we saw you know
200 million plus pizzas a year at
Garlic's toss it's got to be nine to ten
cents a cup so pick a number 15 to 30
million dollars and it's expensive to do
um but we finally found a manufacturer
that could figure out how to get that
lid to stick on that cup without that
garlic sauce going everywhere yeah I
mean listen when that sauce is there if
they order if they deliver the pizza
what I will chase the guy down and also
I'm not taking a pizza until you bring
that and I want it to be hot in so
they'll go back and get it they've never
not had the garlic sauce yeah of course
they have they've showed up House in
Plano two years ago I ordered I'm like
listen I order pizza once every other
month if I do what I'm doing Papa John's
I want to enjoy it I want it to be thick
cheesy just fat is what I want up I'm
gonna have a couple of these slices
right I want it to be thick so anyways
one time a guy forgot about saying I'm
gonna take this back I want it hot and I
want it to be this anyways by the way
for those of you guys that just tuned in
here's what we're going to be doing
stick around in a minute
we're gonna have four of our team
members come in here each of them is
going to call a pizza joint locally here
and they're going to call and order two
pizzas okay and we're gonna see how long
it's gonna take from the moment they
order to deliver it and then we're gonna
have Papa John right here judge all the
pizza buy the looks buy the Box buy The
Taste buy the flavor and then we're
gonna see what's gonna happen so do not
share this video with any of the local
pizza shops matter of fact let's give a
location of where we are right now this
podcast is right now being done from
Vero Beach so if you guys want to call
the people in Vero Beach we're going to
confuse you a little bit we're not in
Indiana we're in Muncie Indiana yeah
we're in Muncie Indiana so okay so at
what point when you start Papa John's
okay
and I think it's 84 if I'm saying I'm
not mistaken I think you start in 84
right you start at 84. at what point
when you started it and it starts going
through what it's going through when did
you say boys team gang we got something
going on here yeah something's taking
place when did you realize you have
something special
um the psychology on this is fascinating
um at store number one we go from the
broom closet to actually open in a
restaurant room closets as I told you is
doing three thousand a week we put a
store next door to the bar it's a
freestanding store and we put a sign on
the door
volume tripled we go from three grand to
nine grand and we're like that's we
didn't know anything about marketing we
just thought if you had the best pizza
you'd win wait wait so you put what sign
we just put a pop of sound sign we
didn't have a sign on the broom closet
we had to we passed out a brochure and
say in the pack of mixed Lounge we
didn't have any sign on the front door
we didn't understand that he put a sign
on the front door sales are going to go
up sales trip triple now we got the bar
doing Seven Grand a week pool tables
doing a thousand and Papa John's next
door's new and 9 000 a week We're Off to
the Races I'm all pumped I'm you know
I'm ready to go I'm excited we go down
to Domino's which about three miles down
the road in Grants Plaza I walk in there
I'm
you know I'm 22 years old sure we're
doing nine thousand yeah I said what are
you doing a week you know
he said we're doing 6 000 a week and I
just basically looked at the guy and I
said we're going to kick your ass in the
whole world you said that basically 22
years old how I thought
with one store because we were whooping
them in Jefferson Indiana we were going
to beat them though but I thought that
way which is crazy most people would be
like
I was scared I was like no if you can
beat him one one place why shouldn't you
beat him in the whole world then let's
fast forward to 2000.
we got like 18 1900 stores we're making
you know 70 million bucks a year
and I'm going through people like
[ __ ] feel good you know I mean I'm
because I mean I'm not I'm Relentless
you know I like the tenacity the
Perfection I'm on it and
we turn the corner we're making 70
million bucks a year
but in my mind we were still broke
I was still back when dad's businesses
were going under and they were turning
off the water turn off the gas
um a year behind on the house payment so
mentally I still think we're broke even
though we're not so I got higher coach
you know I'm still working with guys
like like the greatest one of the
greatest guys and the greatest coach in
the world is Tony Robbins who you know
gives me advice and so I've always had
great coaches along the way so I got
this coach in 99
we're going through this and you know
it's not United it's Tony not even it
wasn't Tony yet if it was Tony I would I
think issues
so but I'm literally like it's my way
the highway if you didn't do it my way
you know it was bad it was it was a
bedevolent dictator
um with an attitude so 99.84 your 62
baby 22 you're 37 years old give or take
30
37 38 years old 37 years old okay and at
this point are you wealthy yeah we're
worth hundreds of millions okay so at
this point you're you're upset I'm sorry
yeah but I didn't I didn't it's still
you asked store number one I thought we
were Invincible we're going to beat
dominoes in the whole world here were
our store 1800 worth the company's
probably worth a billion dollars and I
think I'm still broke I mean you know
because you're you just you know you're
that that's the right mindset though if
you want a little bit of that but you
don't want to be Dennis Rodman operates
out of the state of fear Jack Nicklaus
Tiger Woods operate out of the state of
uh self-esteem of pot you want to
operate you want a little bit of fear
you don't want to be complacent but you
don't want to be that running the show
you want solid sense of self running the
show so I got this coach and this guy's
tough but I didn't care because you know
we and and so he says looks at me he
says
you're worth hundreds of millions of
dollars I go yeah he goes Vietnam's over
I said what do you mean he goes
Vietnam's over Bud he said you're not
gonna turn off your lectures you're not
gonna turn off your water you're not
gonna lose your house payment you're not
gonna lose your house Vietnam's over you
need to wake up hmm and it's stuck it's
like [ __ ] was that good counselor I Was
a Good Counsel Vietnam's been over since
1999 so so meaning in other words let me
interpret that to see if that if I'm if
I'm processing this properly
you stayed in Wartime leader mentality
for too long rather than learning how to
be a peacetime leader since war was
already done and you can figure out
better things you need to do to take the
company to the next level is that kind
of what you're saying I think I learned
that you can operate from the worst in
you a fear or you can operate from the
best in you his words would have been a
dictator versus a Statesman
you know combative collusive versus I
want to know who is this guy a name not
name guy or no is he well-known no no
he's not was he an author or no I don't
know if he had a book or not I think
he's got a book okay cool
cool so he's giving you that mindset so
did it hit you and did you receive it or
were you still fighting and when he told
you that well you're like I don't know
it just it was the finally the button
collect
it just clicked that
okay you got store 1800 nothing wrong
with going to store three thousand you
make a great product you've made your
point now just keep it just went from
they're going to turn off electricity
I'm going to lose the house to look what
I can do to humanity with all this
resources and good how what it really
changed was the culture
where we we always had a culture of
Integrity quality authenticity
win-win we always had that in place
but we started to really obeying natural
law and natural principles
um in fact our golap program was based
on principles uh universal law of mutual
respect kindness thoughtfulness win wins
um compassion
we we really changed the the company
from kind of a transaction based company
to more of a people transformation
company and that happened in that 0105
time period because that's when John
changed
you know and that was the most fun I I
ever had was
um really coming back in 0809
till 16 and 17 that was the funnest run
that was see from 84 to 93 with survival
just survival I mean biological you know
you you eat what you nine ten years of
just trying to survive just trying to
what's your schedule like during that
time what are you doing oh you're
working
um you're working
12 to 14 hours six days a week and
you're working a half a day on Sunday we
did take a half a day we would cut out
at one or two on Sunday by the way
that's from a CEO founder who also had a
similar struggle story that's like the
kind of mindset you're like all right
what kind of how many hours are you even
sleep by the way by the way this is why
some people hate capitalism
because who the hell in the right mind
is willing to listen to this message and
say you want me to go 12 to 14 hours a
day six days a week and half day on
Sunday for 10 years now I'm good bro
totally get it but there's a reason why
the man sitting here is a billionaire
it's not easy to do that it's very very
lonely and it's for hard so okay so
84.93 yeah
93 we go public
we go from where we can't hardly get
three million dollar loan from um
uh National City Bank in Kentucky
Louisville Kentucky three million
dollars what would you give it up when
you went public
do you remember like
30 okay it was a good evening okay good
yeah two where the company's worth 200
million dollars I think it was June uh
June 26 and 93. we go from where I
didn't have five grand to go on vacation
with the family to now I'm worth 100
million bucks one day
but I still felt broke until we really
turned on the measurement system and the
new culture in 0304
I didn't we were successful we made a
lot of money we took the stock from 13 a
share if you look at pre-speed pre-split
probably 130 bucks 10x it was yeah easy
maybe even more I don't know how many
times we split the stock uh so many
times
um but I I it was from the fear of
failure back to the 99 2000 store it was
like I was doing it because I was
worried about going broke so 20 years
you're going with this feeling what was
the first night you slept where you
slept
so 84 you're doing this you're starting
it when did you really sleep because
there's a difference between sleeping
and sleeping
I think you know what I'm asked I think
99 2000 was 16 years were I really kind
of went okay I can um
I can get a good night's I think that
yeah I mean I definitely slept better
this is where I gotta interject her for
a second
you're saying for 15 years you didn't
even sleep no not not didn't sleep
that's no no I didn't I didn't say not
sleep I said sleep good he said this was
the first time that he really gots a
good night's sleep well this goes back
to your point you know what it is to
sleep with that level of fear and
paranoia in someone's after and what if
we go out of business
it's a different kind of that's what I'm
asking that's what I want to tap into
understand that nature and by the way
here's the crazy thing even after you
get the 100 200 300 million in the bank
right because you've been in that state
for so long you still don't know how to
snap out of that state at least that's
my experience yourself
16 years well the we measure the sleep
every night so I'll probably know more
about sleep today yeah yeah but um the
war Rings
If you read the book while we sleep yeah
John's gonna do is read the first page
the amount of things that happen when
you sleep are as far as repair
um I would I'd say I slept but really
not
um and when you when you're in a state
of fear you're in The Reptilian part of
the brain you know it's we call it a
brain regression flight or fight and you
know you're you're repair to your your
body's done in the Newark horoplex uh
cortex the frontal lobe of your body and
I think good night's sleep is more about
getting in the frontal lobe of uh don't
think that if you don't spend the world
the world ain't gonna spin
um a position of okay I'm in this for
everybody to win I'm in this for the
better amount of humanity I'm in this to
better my community I'm in this because
we're proud of what we serve I mean
there's a higher level of Consciousness
that come when you operate from a
position of compassion thoughtfulness
then when you're operating because
you're afraid you're going to get broke
and you're counting your money every day
so but by the way if you're watching
this right now in a few minutes we're
going to call four different pizzas I'm
going to order two pizzas it's going to
come in here we're going to time to see
what delivers on time and Papa John's
going to give us some feedback on this
pizza how it tastes how it looks they're
designed to hold nine and we'll do that
once the live hits the number 35 which
we're getting very close to you hit that
give it a thumbs up if you're enjoying
this podcast so far subscribe to the
channel but I want to go back to this
here so okay at this point just to put
things into perspective
two thousand so 84 16 years you talked
to this man in 99 16th year you're able
to get some rest you're enjoying
yourself a little bit more now so are
you kind of sitting back and saying I've
been working in the business so much let
me see about working on the business
where do we want to go next is that kind
of what happens next not exactly
um remember Christ had 12 disciples and
to preach the gospel and
up till about 88.89
there was
10 12 of us that we could get out and
preach the gospel of what Papa John's
was all about remember we talked about
Croc Sanders there's a culture a
methodology a a process
um idiosyncrasies and every kind of
brand that are intuitive instinctive
that you have to learn
we got about 17 1800 restaurants in
97-98 and we lost our quality there's
simply too many restaurants to go out
there and check on that we did it and so
while we started getting John and head
screwed on
we started moving things from a culture
perspective pretty positive
our product quality had suffered and
this would have been really the second
time that the product quality had gotten
away from us so we had to terminate the
CEO in 2000 and
figure out a way who was a seal I don't
want to say no no oh so you're joking
it's not you it's somebody the CEO oh so
when did you stop being a CEO we stopped
in 2000. well I'm thinking you stayed Co
the entire time chairman okay so you
stopped being a CEO in 2000 okay just
for your audience you had a founder
originates a concept you got a CEO who
runs the whole organization you've got a
chairman of the board who runs the board
who the CEO reports to and then you've
got a spokesperson hi Papa John so I
carry sometimes four hats and sometimes
like today shareholder and founder two
hats
um so who's the most important out of
all those because this was the question
that I had a question CEO is number one
it's not no I have my opinion and I'll
I'll let him answer but I don't think
it's even a question I think the CEO
um
with the founders methods and ideology
assuming
the CEO has the right mindset as a
quality mindset not a production mindset
and knows how to get the right people on
the bus and get them in the right seats
so anyway I retired in 2000 and we
couldn't figure out how do you measure a
million pizzas a day
and we fought we worked on that for
almost a year and had a tomato supplier
out in
Modesto came into Kentucky and we set up
until two three in the morning and
figured out you're never going to
measure a million pizzas a day but what
you can do is manager 65 000 a year in
poll like you do an election and we've
set up a a program to where we had
pictures in service and stop stop
watches in forty fifty thousand homes
throughout the country so we could
monitor the product quality and service
now it
fundamentals in a business are like
staying fit you got to do your emotional
spiritual and physical push-ups every
day you saw those products the product
came in from Jet's Pizza and Papa John's
you saw that when you came in
to get that Papa John's product quality
which was probably a six or seven back
to when I left almost a nine or ten
because you're never going to get to a
10 but you've got to be above an eight
would take a year and a half wear and
tear on me to get them back in shape to
do that that's why I fought so hard the
first two years don't do this don't let
this regime come in here and destroy
your product quality into service
because once you guys lose once you get
80 pounds overweight it's awfully hard
to get back in shape so we fixed the
business from 01 to o5
we had the culture lined up had the
measurement system lined up for back to
Quality uh stock went from 10 bucks back
up to 40 bucks we're on a roll we hired
another CEO
he comes in
first thing he does let's quality soften
make sure the guys in the c-suite get
their stock options the people at the
stores get screwed starts making money
on the food service so 0809 got rid of
him
came back in stock 680 a share that's
when we had that was down from 40 at the
top
40 or 50 from the top now to 680 a share
this October November of 2008 came back
in but now we have the lessons 99 we
have the culture in 2000 2001 and we
also have the measurement system so
within a year year and a half we have
we're back on top we have our go left
culture we're running our business on
principles we got great product quality
great service we're the number one place
to work in Kentucky for six straight
years
we win acsi quality world world world
award in the pizza category 18 19 years
the only restaurant chained to even
compete with this that was better was
Chick-fil-A and so now we took stock
from 680 in 2009 to when I stepped down
in 16 to 88 bucks a share wow whoa
thirteen folds so let me so let me ask
you this question and I'm curious to
know what you're going to say about this
how much of it was uh the new seals you
hired that weren't capable of doing the
job and how much of it was the fact that
you stayed as the chairman it was very
annoying to be reporting to the founder
because they can never be as good as you
so you were always kind of almost not
helping them out you were not because
sometimes you can get in the way as the
founder of the new CEO that you hire
um yes yes and yes okay
yes no well fair enough for you to say
that though you know if you're saying
that
um yeah it's it's it's a toughie we um
how do you find the right man to marry
your daughter you know it's like yeah
it's your baby we groomed a guy
um between myself and the present CEO
the present CEO Papa John's is Rob Lynch
in in the in the the companies in
worship than it was when I was there at
680 a share as far as product quality
service today
oh I mean it's a it's it's not like a
black cloud over it's got a death spiral
I mean why you touch that stock at 85
bucks a share when the product uh is bad
uh the service is bad the franchisees
are not making the money they were
making their traffic cancel is down
um they you International comps negative
eight
um Russia it's in the tube
um UK's in the tube China wouldn't
Taiwan hits is going to be in the tube I
mean there's nobody building stores in
the U.S you have no growth
um if you take their Philadelphia
franchisee two years ago we're gonna
build 49 stores in Philadelphia that
guy's gone he's not gonna open any
stores the guy they signed up in Texas
getting ready to open 100 stores I don't
think he's opened any
um the traffic counts uh they've got
probably about 18 million new customers
or traffic counts are like negative
hypothetical four six eight ten twelve
percent you know if I was an analyst I
would say give me the Market's going to
grow in outside of Russia Poland Germany
UK China how come International comps
are negative eight how come UK is in the
tank how come your traffic count in the
U.S you've got all these new customers
is negative how come you've lost uh the
acsi award the last couple years how's
your franchisee doing in Dallas how's
they doing in Pennsylvania and by the
way how much money did your corporate
restaurants make in August just ask a
question what are your transactions what
did corporate stores made in August if
they would answer that question honestly
I bet the analysts I bet they'd Run for
the woods well I'm glad you're being
very gentle about the way you're putting
them on blast it was very you know the
way you went about it if they're
listening to it right now the founder
who started this company is calling now
a product today with Papa John's which
we'll find out here in a minute when we
order because it breaks my heart because
I you know I've been I've been garlic
sauce yeah the customer question for you
Papa John when you're saying all this
essentially kind of throwing your
namesake in in the mud are you disgusted
by it does it upset you or you're like
well you know when I was there maybe
you're more proud of what you were able
to accomplish like how do you feel
basically saying everything you just
said about the company where it's at now
we've been through this now three times
where every time I leave they get away
from the principles they get away from
the quality get away from their service
get away from their transparency
um but so is there an emotion that this
is there's an emotion what's that
emotion if you could put a name to it uh
you first of all you hurt for the
employees because when this this went
down this started three years ago four
years ago and they don't care about the
employees and we're not in the pizza
business we're in the people business I
mean there's three 400 families in
Louisville that just got left hanging
because they just picked up and went to
Atlanta
um all the good employees that were
there 10 15 20 25 years are gone so no
regard for people and the thing that I
try to do is I tried to save the
employees I tried to save the
franchisees and employees I could do
they just moved so quick you know they
just they didn't they didn't care and
they wanted to cut G A franchisees I've
been telling them for some time hey you
know pay attention to your food quality
we've been through this we've seen this
movie before you get your service and
then covert came along you got a
monopoly got a captive audience where
people were sitting at home consuming
alcohol you can charge a higher number
because people are trapped and they got
free money entitlements and so this last
two years they've had a free ride that's
the worst thing that could have happened
to Rob Lynch the CEO of Papa John's
because he thought it was easy
he was he got caught flat-footed and now
they let the product and the service
lift image slip what they should have
been doing the last two years is getting
ready for this day when kovid's gone and
we're back to reality they got caught
flat-footed and now they're they're in a
you know in the spiral downward because
the reason we just mentioned by the way
the same can be said for everyday
Americans that were every all the
entitlements were talking about the
stimulus that you're getting the um
free free money that was going out there
people got lazy and then obviously that
you see what's happening now we talked
about this February March of 2020 on the
interviews the thing most dangerous
about this is the psychology habits are
formed in 18 days solidified in 44 in
three months it's a lifestyle we've been
sitting around for three years with free
money I I worry about the psychology of
getting free money and not have to make
a contribution you know socialism is
taken from people that produce and
rewarding to people that don't produce
that's what we've been doing for three
years well we know it doesn't work it's
a it's it's an idea that
um
it comes out of a place that's never
been proven no one's ever proven that
this system works and America proved no
system has uh provided better innovation
in the world than the concept of
capitalism no country has done a better
job uh doing that than we have so they
can give the argument as much as they
want hey Pat before we transition I
really want to get your feedback on that
initial question I had he said you said
oh there's no question as to who the
most important is I asked CEO founder uh
director of the board uh the
spokesperson the president you said no
question I did and then he answered I
think you said the the founder and the
CEO of their envisions in line Visions
none of these is as hard okay who's got
a tougher job Biden Trump Obama Bush
Clinton Reagan or Washington
Washington that's not even a question
about it who's got a harder job you know
Tim Cook or Steve Jobs and Wozniak
it's not even a question to see the
founder the founder has it's a very very
emotionally taxing and not just on you
on everybody in your family that's
involved with you your spouse your kids
your everybody a Founder's life is not a
sexy life it's just not that's just the
reality of it there's nothing sexy about
being a Founder while you're a Founder
the first 10 15 years he said he got no
sleep no but but it's not that it's it's
a very honorable profession it's a not
very honorable uh position to be in but
it comes with a lot of Burden it's not
the most you know people think oh look
at this Foundry he's worth what he's
worth oh yeah go ahead do it again well
matter of fact if you do it I'll give
you twice as much money as he makes go
ahead and do it go see
this is what you summarized in your 90
second video the life of an entrepreneur
right it's not for everybody so when you
run it you know when you run into if
when I go and run into somebody that's
got a military unit form on I'll say
thank you for your service when I run
into a cap I'll say thank you for your
service if I go to a restaurant yeah or
small business where the owner is there
I'll say thank you for your service and
so what do you mean by I was never in
the military yeah but you're running a
business and you're creating jobs and
because of you I get to pay less taxes
because these people are getting paid by
you not by taxpayers like me thank you
for your service so more people should
stop by business owners and tell them
thank you for your service because it's
not an easy job it's a very hard job to
do thank you for your service yeah my
pleasure yeah there's no question by the
way at the peak how many pizzas were you
guys selling at the peak Peak peek when
you were there how many were you guys
selling I think we were right at a man a
day 360 million pizzas something like
that million pizzas a day I know it was
a crazy number one Super Bowl Sunday the
last year I was there I I think we did
20 million dollars or 20 million it was
a crazy number 20 million I went 20
million pizzas maybe it was 20 million
bucks in one day that was like yeah
that's intense well we used to do that
we used to do 200 a day and thought we
were rich in the broom clock but that's
the cool thing though it doesn't matter
I mean that's the story so look let's
let's address one thing we're about to
order the pizzas here in a minute and
then I'm going to go into some of the
other other issues that we got but let's
address one thing so
um all of a sudden one day I'm looking
at the new saying you know Papa John is
stepping down okay hey he's resigning
the board is asking him to resign he's
choosing to resign all that mess that
took place
then I said how did this just happen
this doesn't make any sense to me for
what happened
so you know America we know we're all
about innocent until proven guilty
sometimes the media is more about guilty
until proven innocent which they take a
different model
than innocent until proven guilty I
listened to the recording I listened to
the 54 minute call whatever the 54
minute I think it's a 54 minute Zoom or
call that they had I listened to the
call that they had I listened to their
conversations I read the menus you know
I went through it to just kind of see
for myself why don't you take a moment
and if you don't mind share you know
what happened the day where you were
essentially forced to resign from the
company
um what led to those events
I think
um
I knew something was up when you when
you when you run a business you've got
pretty good intuition
and they you know
um exacerbated the Obama comments NFL I
said hey just solve it to the owners and
player satisfaction they painted that in
the kneeling somehow I mean it just they
kept doing it and I'm like and my
company would never step in and say well
that's not what he said just read the
transcript unfortunately everything I've
done there's a transcript and
um and and there's no history of of race
there's no history of not treating
everybody with kindness with love
compassion and respect
but I felt something
comment that was going on behind the
scenes but I didn't think it was an
inside job
I thought I thought it was coming from
the DNC or from the outside it ended up
being it was a combination of both
um but when they they said they set this
up with a laundry service
and laundry service leaked a false
narrative to what I said actually what I
said was anti-racist
um and they painted as racist
um mischaracterized it the thing I asked
the board is I said slow down I can
remember this coming down on a Tuesday
we had a board meeting I said just slow
down let's make sure you all know what I
said you know my heart you know there's
no history of of this kind of um you
know mindset Behavior feelings towards
anybody
um on Prejudice and I couldn't get the
board to slow down so Wednesday they
said hey if you would step down as
chairman
um then that would solve the problems
one of the board members Sonia media
called me the next day and said you know
by stepping down as chairman you you
saved the company this is on a Thursday
and so
um
I stepped down more to just kind of let
things settle down a little bit and then
on Friday uh they said we're gonna have
emergency board meeting on Sunday
and then Saturday that week so less than
six days we went from where chairman
um principal shareholder
founder spokesperson the word that
Sunday they uh they actually kicked me
to the street
um now I mean I was lawyer chairman I
wasn't even in the office and I lost my
employment agreement so I think the
thing the lesson there is as a company
and corporate board member you have a
fiduciary duty to do an investigation
the Civil committee and do an
investigation and get to the bottom of
what happened
this board because I think I had some
board members on board I know I did that
had self-interest that wanted me out one
of the directors Mark Shapiro the other
director Steve Ritchie Mark Shapiro got
a a 10 million dollar package and got
the 40 million dollar marketing business
um after uh I was ousted as chairman and
Richie got a six million dollar year
package because we were getting ready to
terminate him for the reasons we talked
about so we had two board members that
were uh kind of on the inside had a weak
board
corporate board they really didn't
understand the business I think they
bought into a bad bill of goods with
Mark Shapiro and Steve Ritchie and they
overreacted and due to their corporate
Duty and just did a tremendous damage to
the brand but not getting to the bottom
of exactly what I said and not having
some kind of Defense in and by the
company not having any defense and not
taking a position to support the founder
they're complicit
yeah and you know what's interesting so
I I dug into this because sometimes as a
business owner and you got strong
opinions and you're vocal about it you
got to be careful because you're a
Target and I'm somebody that runs
businesses and I have strong opinions
and you know there are a lot of people
that don't like that so for somebody
like me I said let me take you as a case
study and I'm gonna look because there's
many case studies like yours I said let
me take him
as a case study so in 2012 I want to say
you're at an event
and you made some comments about
Affordable Care Act on a class on
entrepreneurship in a shareholder
conference call you said that you oppose
ACS because your best estimate was that
Obamacare was going to cost you around
11 to 14 cents per Pizza okay that's
what the article wrote about you with
what it says but look at the content you
kind of just did a little bit what they
do I said delivery charge is 250 275 a
pizza yeah Obamacare is only 12 or 13
cents it's not a big deal we can absorb
it I disagree with it but it's not a
problem for us because of our volume and
the amount of transactions we have yeah
but but what I'm my point is
a businessman has to look at these
numbers like you just said like garlic
costs nine cents and if we're doing 20
million a year that's you know 200
million that's a real money if you're
doing some number like they send 365
let's just say do 365 million pots you
know uh pizzas per year and each Pizza
has one of those garlic sauce nine cents
that's number that you got to look at
you said 15 to 30 million and garlic
sauce I believe it depends on how many
they do if they do 365 it's more like
you know 35 million not yeah 35 million
bucks in garlic yes
so but but but you have to understand if
you're a Founder uh and you're the
spokesperson and if you say listen if my
costs go up I just pass them on to the
consumer the left will attack you for
saying what I just said but guess what
if you're in the business and the costs
go up you pass it home
that's yeah I mean do you not it's
common sense it has to look like
California I don't know if you're
selling California by the way I'll tell
you what I did I see you just so you
know I'll let you know so when I'm uh
one of the guys shows up your guy runs a
restaurant in uh Mexican restaurants in
California he's got 38 of them okay so
he said did you hear about the new law
that just got passed for restaurant
chains with over a hundred locations I
said yeah I heard about it so he says
this is going to impact this so let me
take a look at it so I'm looking into it
it says well they're raising the minimum
wage did you see the number they're
raising the minimum two dollars
in California
per employee working at a restaurant
that's got a hundred hundred chains or
more okay so if it's 15 going to 22
that's a 50 increase and restaurants
margins generally are what three to five
percent if a burger is four bucks
overnight it's six dollars so if the
customer says I can't believe these guys
are raising it it's not these guys
raising it is 22 dollars that's the
minimum wage that the price is being
paid okay so the guy that the business
owner says he's like Pat how do I handle
this I said you have to handle it by
being prepared for this so you got to
raise your cost and tell the explain to
the customer here's what we have to do
because he's simply having a
conversation with the board to say this
is what it's going to cost us I'm not
offended by this I'm expecting a guy to
be talking about this because if you
don't maybe you're not the right guy to
pay attention to these types of costs so
then next is you were at the Romney deal
and I think you something happened with
Romney at a fundraise he hosted a
fundraiser for Romney in May of 2012 and
you've said good things about Trump I
think contributed towards him and then
there were some things that was in 2017
and then right afterwards this event
takes place right with your situation so
I I said let me go read into what you
said because believe it or not I thought
this entire time you said the the N word
okay do you know the story with uh how
did you listen to the recording I did I
watched the whole thing there was a
Colonel Sanders reference yes I think
it's important for him to address it
yeah so it was a you know in 2017 on the
earnings conference called the NFL was
hurting and more importantly by not
resolving the current debacle in NPA
players NFL players satisfaction NFL
leadership has heard Papa John's
shareholders okay fine it's a call out
to the NFL they're not going to be happy
about it this should have been nipped in
about a year ago fine and then it says
Papa John's founder used n-word on a
conference call so what so what what's
the context here then you hear the
recording questions in the first place
because you know wasn't intentional was
sensitive but the word was even Colonel
Sanders called blacks then you don't say
n word you say the actual word
and I'm like I've never used this word
before so then it goes back in the
marketing agency's recording comes back
on what they were trying to do to get
him down and hey we just have to get him
to speak the truth and you know want him
to write down bullet points and let them
go and anyways Jake this guy named Jason
Stein is saying what he's saying then
you're kind of watching us saying well
look these guys were not necessarily
coming from a place of trying to help
you as a marketing agency they were kind
of coming from a place of seeing hey
what can we do to you rather than help
you but to the market unfortunately in
today's Times all they see is this guy
must be a racist and and for me
this is how I view it
if let's just say you're somebody we go
to a bar
and all of a sudden you have a drink
and after a drink you look at a guy he
says something to you punch him in the
face
oh my God what the hell was that all
about
then I call around some of your friends
and say oh yeah Adam's known for that
what do you mean Adam's known for that
Adam does that all the time seriously
yeah one time we were in high school he
did this to that guy one time we went to
a club he did that to that guy I can
tell you I've seen Adam do that 20 times
well guess what there is a trend but if
this happens on a call like this in 2017
and you've been in business since 1984.
how many total W-2 employees have you
had all these years how many people
would come out and say yeah he called me
that as well here's that word as well he
would do see that's that's the
investigative journalism that doesn't go
that deep to show that and then all they
do is people jump to conclusion and boom
now you got somebody that's not running
the brand which all of us if we watch
Sunday football who would you see you
would see you know yeah you know so many
times in my life the fact that he's
sitting here but there but there is a
point here for somebody that's gone
through it yourself that's gone through
this situation here we had
at an event I hosted last week in uh
natala it was the last week was last
last week two weeks ago I'm sorry ten
days ago we had an event at the Diplomat
and we brought Chas palm and Terry who
did the one-man show Bronx Tale oh man
we had Robert Kiyosaki there we had the
number one Illusionist in America good
friend of mine Frederick de Silva there
we have Kevin Connolly from Entourage
the show Entourage
and we have Andy fast style I don't know
if you know Andy fast that was Andy fast
as the former CFO of Enron who went to
jail for eight years wow and he had a
hundred thousand employees everyone's
like why would you invite Andy fastau I
said so I'm trying to keep you guys out
of jail you got to pay attention to
accountant you think this is just making
money so he came up
and this is his opening talk one of the
best talks you'll see he says this is me
he shows the magazine
your prior to this I was recognized as a
CFO of the year
the next year this is my personality ID
card okay one year ago I'm the CFO of
the year the next year on this and he
tells his own story so for some people
that are becoming you know maybe they're
have a business plan and they're not
low-key maybe they have a following
maybe they have a voice maybe they have
some political leanings maybe they have
some strong opinions
what feedback would you give to other
Founders CEOs and entrepreneurs to be
careful with in a climate like this
where everything is so you're walking on
eggshells and it's a cancer culture type
of an environment what feedback would
you give to operators like that I think
several
um one is people always usually asking
their own act in their own best
interests
you have a board of directors that hired
a CEO that had an agency that sets the
the founder the face of the brand up
and betrays the false narrative that is
a racist
who in the right mind
tell me how that's in anybody's best
interest the shareholders franchisees
employees the founder the board it's in
nobody's at best interest unless you're
watching them and you want ahead of the
DNC because you know I'm involved with a
lot of things that involve
entrepreneurship I mean so from my
perspective there's no way I could have
seen this coming because you wouldn't
think back to the inside job that people
would act in something that's so far in
everybody's worst interest the second
thing is
the okay I was set up false narrative
shouldn't have repeated Colonel Sanders
but the intent it's a good heart and you
know
slurs or anything like that it's all
about what you meant and what you felt
and and there was no nothing but
um love and kindness in the history
there's no
um history this kind of repeated offense
there's no priors is what you're saying
of course not
um
but let's get the two inch violin out
let's do a 10 second pity party for John
now let's get on with life because the
universe always works for me it never
works against me sometimes it felt like
it now why I had to go through what I
went through to get to why where I'm why
I'm sitting here I don't know but you
got to take that position and I Look at
California 22 bucks I look at Ukraine
and Russia I look at
um you know this labor market for some
reason
uh my it was my time to get out of that
situation
I wouldn't have done it that way I'd let
I'd have given a decent burial but it
wasn't my choice they overreacted they
panicked they did a lot of damage and
they it's done it's done they will be
held accountable so I think moving
forward you got to go okay
what did I learn from that and to learn
the thing is in your 90 second tape
you know you wake up every day and you
make it happen and so I don't know what
the universe has in store for me I can
tell you the four principles the four uh
characteristics is me that I want to
have
um but that that other opportunity to
come along and we'll do something bigger
and better for Humanity that's better
than the bar better than the pizza and
um you know my four criteria are it's
got to be in my soul it's got to be part
of it it's got to be authentic it's got
to be real it's got to be truthful too
it's it's got a better Humanity if I'm
not better than my fellow man that's why
I hated the bar pizza was fun I brought
friends and family together but it's
processed food let's face it I want
something that's going to improve
Humanity I want something I can scale up
because I like big stuff I like making
an impact and fourth is it's got to be
sustainable I don't want to be feeding
every month so until I come across those
four things that are in my being in my
fabric of my soul then I'll just have to
sit tight and be patient remember I'm an
entrepreneur I'm allergic to patients so
this is very difficult it's in here for
three years and not do a whole lot of
anything but I'm I'm doing it can I can
I assume what you have been doing
uh when you when you were going through
all this uh permission to speak freely
here you didn't look your best you were
probably 30 pounds heavier 40 pounds
heavier you look great right now so I
assume you've been working on yourself
inside outside emotional physical all
that fun stuff you know people I kind of
go you know when this went down did you
hit rock bottom the answer is no because
the people that did this I loved them I
loved them and I protected them and I I
mean I made them all multi-millionaires
this went down July of 18. it wasn't
until January February 19
where I finally had to come to grips
where they really did do this people
that I really care about really it was
so painful to see that I would just go
blind I wouldn't see it and that was
that was the hardest moment
um I don't know January February March
of 19 whereas
these these people really did this I
mean they did they painted me as a
racist I mean can you imagine being the
founder the spokesperson taking that
thing from 640 a share to the company's
worth three and a half billion and the
people that are around you they're
supposed to be protecting you hired an
agency and set you up I didn't want to
see it and so you had to get you had to
get back to get out of denial and get
right back to they did it now from there
you keep harping on it
you're angry you're jealous you're
vindictive well [ __ ] that's no way to go
she just got to kind of go all right I
forgive them
but I didn't forget their name you're
whatever you're wherever you're at a
question about it and you know you just
move on and you just start trusting the
university trust in a higher power and
you just know that
um you know there's something bigger and
better lying ahead you know uh
Pizza when you hire Pizza employees they
don't have mbas they don't have they
hire people like me like when I was 18
I'm mortgage I'm going to be working on
places like that right so I'm not
somebody I'm Middle Eastern so Pizza
people hire what minorities that's who
you hire so he you've had many many many
many chances to offend those communities
you haven't it so happens that you do
that in that sense now look for us I
don't think in any context it's it's to
to use that uh uh word just the other
day I'm playing a video by Fat Joe and I
was uncomfortable because he kept saying
like well it you know it is what I
listened today I'm working out with eat
in the morning six o'clock in the
morning you know what I'm listening to
the workout who do you think I'm
listening to and I'm working out today
I'm listening to Troublesome I'm
listening to life goes on I'm listening
to you know uh uh all I need in this
life is sin is me and my you know I'm
listening to hit them up this morning
I'm working out and I'm sitting with
Jimbo and we're working out right now
some people say hi you've lost your mind
gets me going at the gym now so so
sometimes we're around it but I'm glad
you were open to talking about that
appreciation for doing that being a good
sport about it because again in business
nowadays what I hear a lot when we're
doing consulting with different folks
this is starting to become more of an
issue today than before so it's
constantly coming up yeah the the two
things that I'm most thankful for going
through this for some reason the public
knew this was dirty pool they knew this
had a stent they never bought into this
whole that the whole story they didn't
buy into the job and I I mean usually
the public is kind of gullible
and the second thing is I I have a tape
they left the tape the dumbasses left
the tape fronted and I have the tape
that says you know we you know we
basically hope he gets out of the
pasture we hope this guy gets screwed
because we're part of it so I'm we got
him by the throat they set me up they
mischaracterized what I said
um they reversed the intent of what I
said and the public never bought it in
the first place so how lucky am I well
it's based on that I think that's the
best transition to see let's see how
their Pizza is doing so Eric if you want
to bring everybody in here real quick we
are going to do a social experiment
right now a social experiment that we
just thought about last minute uh uh if
you guys want to head in here and and
don't break the bank's vault door
okay so what about Neil who Neil has
entered the building so everybody come
over here come around come on come
around Natalia come on Natalia who we
got Rob as well in his suit today so
nice to meet you how you doing what's
your name sir nice this girl I recognize
this girl right here doing how you doing
how you doing okay Natalia so here's
what we're gonna do here's what we're
gonna do Rob I asked you to get numbers
to four local pizza joints okay right we
said four of them yeah we have four so
each of you is gonna call one of them
simultaneously you're gonna step out and
you're gonna we're gonna time it I'm
gonna give you the time on when you
called it okay okay you're gonna get the
number ready to call and you're gonna
tell us who you're calling you're gonna
order a regular pizza okay a pepperoni
pizza and the works right is that what
we agreed on John those are the two
we're doing yeah we'll do peps in the
works okay pepsin works okay that's what
you're doing and then we're gonna wait
to see how long it takes to come we'll
time it Eric as they come in here to the
front door somebody's just got a timer
32 minutes 28 minutes 26 minutes 59
minutes whatever the time is going to be
well hopefully with the podcast
and we'll judge this pizza by somebody
who's been in this space for quite a
while so he kind of knows the pizza game
well so the moment we say three two one
first of all Who you calling Natalia
who's yours okay so you're calling Pizza
Hut
Papa John's
Domino's Jets Jets get your phones ready
everybody on three two one I'll let you
know to dial three two one dial 323 you
guys can step up you guys can step out
you guys can step out and go place your
orders
and don't mention a guy we know named
Papa John okay
hi 323. hey Neil good to see you buddy
3 23 it is to see how long this is gonna
take what'd you say
are they already calling
yes okay sounds good all right so let's
get back into this here today
um do you still eat pizza I eat pizza
yeah do you do you make it yourself or
is it do you order it do you I've got a
pizza oven at home okay the key to the
the pizza is really the oven and the
dough and so I'll get some dough from
Papa John's or get some dough from my
friends at Jet's Pizza and then once you
got the dough right in the oven right
you can kind of you can kind of wink it
from there now which dough is more
important dough as in bread or dough as
in money which which dough would just
because you got both of them so
without the first dough I wouldn't have
the second though so probably the first
though the people though right I think
money talks and Bs walks I think you
gotta go with the cash you got to go
with the cash is what you got to go yeah
so today with uh uh everything that's
going on you were talking about a lot of
different things with in regards to
Pizza uh I got a couple guys that I know
that run pizza shops is this a time
where a small business owner kind of
like yourself that came out and you go
you were telling the Ray Kroc story as
the founder how he went from not being
the first Burger King was there already
you know all the other guys were is this
a good time to open up a pizza business
you know I started at Reaganomics in
1984 when I founded Papa John's you know
we had a leader that was small
regulation
uh pro-business Pro small business
um you know what it was just saying the
most dangerous words in the English
language are um I'm from the government
and I'm here to help yeah uh small you
know smaller taxes I grew up with that
and I mean how lucky was I
um you know we're this this situation
this Administration is just anti-small
business and um
I I don't like what when you've you can
have empathy for
um folks when you've walked them out on
their shoe I mean you know I told you we
cut grass when I was eight painted
gutters when I was 12.
um did the bar when I was 21 started
Papa John's when I was 20. I mean uh
even when we got big we were a family of
small businesses you know average
franchisee had what three or four stores
so my love and affection and
appreciation and respect for small
businesses probably second to nine
I mean if I was going to like let's take
a Papa John franchisee you know you're
you're getting involved with a company
that's let the quality slip let the
service slip uh unit economics
um you know I'm not sure 30 40 50 of the
stores out there are not making money or
breaking even
um you had this issue with the founder
that you got a board that hired a CEO
hired an agency that caused a huge mess
and really tainted the brand is that
team still there that got rid of you
no the CEO that did this got uh got
fired
um probably 10 months after I left they
fired the CEO that did this
um but by that time they were already in
defaulted of the loans it didn't take
long to Crater Papa John's when I left I
mean we this went down July of 18 and by
November of 18 they were already in
default of the loans in their loan
covenants it went down quick after I
left and then covet saved him for a
couple years and now the Sox left today
that it was when I was there in 16.
but my biggest concern for a potential
Papa John franchisee and the franchisees
who were there now who I know and love
is this IRS thing
um you know you saw last night when Mike
Landell was rated with the FBI Trump
just got raided I mean we now have Nazi
Germany where if you're a conservative
and you believe in conservative
principles and you're outspoken you've
got the KGB
um you believe that the AG the FBI uh
you know the internal um Revenue Service
now I mean yeah the the government is
now an enemy of the the freedoms of the
people and if you don't think that you
know if they attack Lindell Trump Flynn
Papa John if they attack us sooner or
later they're going to attack every
American that doesn't believe in their
ideology that has a voice and you came
from Iran I've talked to people from
Hungary
um Lebanon uh Pakistan I mean that you
all know exactly what we're dealing with
Cuba Venezuela I mean you all know that
this is not fun stuff with their when
when the state controls the media
and the state controls the government
agencies that can
perpetrate and
hurt the people that are supposed to be
protecting our freedoms you're dealing
with a very dangerous situation here and
by the way they're not they don't hide
what they do they're very open because
they want to intimidate you so folks
like the three of us don't talk about
what they're doing but this is a very
dangerous situation when the state
controls the media and controls the
agencies which are going after our
freedoms our individual freedoms our
freedom of speech Etc
do you think uh uh this strategy they're
taking is sustainable long term or you
think eventually it's going to come to a
stop or do you think people have to
stand up today or else it could end up
being something that stays for a while
if it continues then we are
down the path where we reward people
that don't work with monies from people
that do work that's socialism I mean it
would show me anywhere in the history of
man where socialism hasn't decreased the
quality of life for its uh citizens
so this is yeah this is going to get
it's going to have to get I mean this
midterm is crucial to stop and the the
you know the kind of the KGB
uh Nazi gestapo kind of
um
mindset and ideology has been promoted
by the upper left right now I think this
is critical do you think that last night
we're having dinner
at a restaurant I've never been before
called Casa D'Angelo yeah which I go
there three or four times a week I was
at Angelo today
and we're sitting down having a good
dinner with a few of our friends and one
of the questions comes up at the end
after two and a half hours of dinner do
you think he's going to get indicted do
you think that's going to happen
if you watch some Outlets Left Right
Center some are saying yes
all have left the same yes some of
writers starting to say yes
uh question number one do you think
you'll get indicted number two if he
does what will happen who are you
talking about Trump from yeah okay
if you're Trump
and you weren't prepared for this and
you didn't set a booby trap
then you deserve what you're going to
get
because you you know he had to know that
they were going to come after him
and if you don't think that way if I'm
not thinking that way I'm thinking that
way five moves ahead Landell was
thinking that way you're in our shoes
you got to be knowing what they're going
to do
Steve bannon's been out saying they're
going to raid Mar-A-Lago now for six
months 12 months so what Trump should
have had was a picture of binders I mean
there should have been something in
there where it made them all look like
fools
but you know if he had classified
documents that really are unclassified
because he has the right to do that he's
got to know that even though he
unclassified him they say top secret
perception wise they're gonna kill him
but he has to know that he's a smart guy
he's a smart of the three of us put
together so if he got sloppy and and he
wouldn't want to put it on you know put
all over the office floor he didn't do
that that was that was a setup by the uh
the FBI but if he did not prepare for
them to do what they did not knowing
that they're going to twist it remember
I said Colonel Sanders says it I would
never say it lost my company you they
will twist the slightest little thing
and destroy you he's got to know that
and if he left himself wide open he's
going to pay the price
so so your answer is it could he could
post possibly be indicted
okay remember the covet vaccines uh
before then they had
um I'm not gonna chlorine hydroxy
chloroquine and then help me with other
I'm acronym okay the one there that's
really the one that does that imacrum of
both hydroxychloroquine and both I'm
I've never met ivermect them will keep
you from getting sick
um he put hydroxychloroquine out there
because he knew it would work and he
knew the left would shoot it down
because he promoted it he did that
intentionally to leave The Other Drug
where you get access to it he's a smart
guy I mean he's a smart guy he knows
what he's doing I can't believe that he
would leave himself that wide open
especially with lawyers what's your uh
split is it 50 50 80 20. yeah he's
indicted yeah
we the market crashed yesterday that
just changed the whole election what 54
days out so it
depends on what day it is I I think
I I think that the left will do anything
to get the focus that the American
public's attention Off fuel prices
devaluating the dollar inflation uh the
war the uh botched the funding of the
police anything to get the public off
the real issues and on to Trump or
something else I think that the media
will do it though because the media is
simply an arm uh for the left so I mean
if it'll sell newspapers and draw
attention from the real issues I think
the left will go that far with this so
you're you're more of a it's more likely
to happen than not to happen
that's kind of what you're saying that's
how I took it well now Kai I'm sending
you a few pictures prepare those please
I think
the odds of trump not being prepared for
this
are very low so you're saying he's ready
for it if they do indict him if he
wasn't prepared for this then shame on
him
he's now had four years to know that
he's dealing with the devil and the
devil plays dirty on every corner and if
he he's a proactive guy just so I think
he is ready now whether uh this AG files
uh indicts him or not that's that's
that's just simply you know the the
craziness of the left because you know I
don't think even if he didn't do
anything wrong which again he can
declassify whatever he says he can
declassify if they find the technicality
well you Declassified but you didn't
follow the right process
then he's done I guess we're going to
find out here soon what happens there by
the way you were an operator from 84 to
say 18 uh uh 34 years of running a
business from zero to a multi
multi-billion dollar company right three
and a half billion dollar company
uh uh yeah that's pretty intense to do
something like that very few people in
America have done that but the question
becomes uh how closely are you following
the markers because for you
the pizza business you have to follow
Market closely because your customer is
low in Middle income families and sports
fans so everything matters to you like
when 9 11 happens probably you can track
back to what happened to your business
whether it was good or not or when you
know 2008 happened 2007 when the market
tank 38 you you have to see what that
was a good year for us because people
went from buying high-end phone to do I
realize they can afford only buy pizza
so we did well or this did well when you
look at the different markers today okay
well what we have amount of money we
printed we've seen inflation we're
seeing you know gas prices we're seeing
what happened to the stock market
yesterday we're seeing loan officers
refinancing business out mortgage rates
are up now you know six percent five
point nine percent if you got a 650
credit score all this stuff that's
happening there's and then you hear the
camp we're not on recession we know the
definition of recession we know all this
stuff
have we hit bottom yet it's at 31 thou
right now if you look at Dow today is
that 31 give or take right it went up a
little bit but not a lot of it but it's
around 31 000 down
how low do you think it'll go it's at
thirty thousand nine fifty two is where
it closed it ended up being down 152.
are we at the bottom or do you think
with the things that's going on we're
still got some more room to go lower
than 30 950 today
well I can tell you one of three things
the market will go up it'll stay the
same it'll go down
that's what's going to happen who knows
um Market December when Trump was still
in office of 19 the market was 20 29-7
30 000. so we're within four percent of
what it was and Trump was in office
um
the
I
I invest to where if the market goes to
40
I do real well
I hit all if the market stays at 35 I
still get my dividend income and I'm
fine with that and if the market crashes
I've got a fund called The Black Swan
Universal it's a Black Swan event last
time the market went from 29-7 down to
20 that was up 4 000 times 4 000 percent
so it's a real hedge fund so I'm in a
position where whatever happens
um I love it's called Almost fatigue
a-r-m-o-r for TF f-i-t-i Omar fatigue
love thy faith so no matter what happens
I love my fate now
the I think the market is sketchy to go
down
but remember Black Swan events are not
predictable I.E they're printing money
we got a war in Taiwan potentially uh
war in Ukraine Black's water events are
a dice though you can pick
a dice with six sides you can pick a
dice with 120 sides
um 120 sides is about all you can get
for it becomes a marble and it really
doesn't never stop interesting so what
the bet is here's the BET gentlemen
here's your Black Swan here's your
Universal I'm going to bet you that
those 120 dice because what goes on in
the world probably 120 but we're kind of
getting the mathematics I'm gonna bet
you pops up one on all three dices
and I'm gonna pay you 30 cents a day to
bet you that does on my ten thousand
dollar investment and it and that takes
about 10 years to go through that 30
cents or whatever it is now believe it
or not
sooner or later all those three dies are
going to show up all once
that's a Black Swan don't know when has
nothing to do with Mark so what I do is
we've already had a 36 7 Dow that's down
to 31. so that's 5700 what's that 70
percent 16 to 18 percent okay a lot of
folks have taken a haircut I think the
nasdaq's down 30. so this is a good
place to where at least you've avoided
the first 20 or 30 percent
um I think
now I'm this is the I never pay
attention to Marcus unless they go way
up or they go way down this morning
before I came over here I'm watching the
markets because we're playing I call my
Blackjack money you know where I
actually I don't really it's not enough
money to water shotgun for the net worth
but it makes me feel like I'm doing
something okay and so we're we're buying
what we do is we buy on the way down so
the old entry point was 35 000 we feel
to your point things are shakier now our
entry points more like 30 to 33 000 the
farther goes down the more I load up so
it averages so one or two things yeah is
that you know so say you put in 2
million it
thirty three thousand down added 28 000
you may put in 20 million but you're
going to pull that average down now if
it runs back up okay your dividend
stocks go up because they go over the
markets you got your dividends and you
make money on your blackjack
if it crashes you kick it in the teeth
with your Black Swan
the only thing the only way to lose is
if you have a death of a thousand small
Cuts where it goes what it's done now 36
35 34 32 31 30 29 it does we need we
need a ten percent either kicking the
teeth we need this to get back up to 40
000. I think um I think there's so much
going on that's unknown that's very
dangerous that the market should be
sketchy
but that makes rational sense markets
are never rational it's an emotional
game and so you just got to know that
um it's an emotional game so I don't
think I answered one bit of your
question well you should run for office
because I was like you you simply gave
uh uh you know answers on dollar cost
average and a few different things but
nothing was ever answered you know it
wasn't answerable just out of curiosity
when you're looking at this this story
came out I'm curious to know how you're
going to speculate this a record 19
million Americans asked
the IRS for tax extensions nearly one in
eight American asked the IRS for more
time to file here's what you need to
know
uh about the October 17 deadline do when
you read this why do you think record
breaking 19 million Americans ask the
IRS for tax extensions
is that a consistent number through time
or is that a once no this isn't this is
the highest ever record 19 million we've
never had 19 million Americans ask to
extend
their taxes with the IRS well you know
just shooting from the hip I'd say that
folks are thinking they're getting ready
to get audited and then they're checking
you know their you know measuring three
times going to cut once to make sure
what they turn in is accurate I think
they're asking for an extension so their
accuracy of their tax return is
something that they can't come back on
that's how I read it how do you read it
I I actually Wonder like why are people
asking for tax extensions is it because
they overextended themselves and they
don't have the money to pay what they're
thinking they're gonna owe is it because
they overspend is it because it's pretty
strange to have this kind of a number at
a season like this well I'll give you a
number that's kind of scary is that the
normal GDP of the government to our GDP
is about 15 16 last two years
undercovered it's been more like 30. so
it's double so this we got a little
taste of socialism socialism is when
your DDP gets above 25 30 percent that's
when people get entitlements and they
get a free lunch and they stop working
so what the article was saying was a
variety of factors is to blame Beyond
just procrastination uh taxpayers say
shifting dude due dates covet related
tax law changes
late forms the IRS backlog and taxpayer
burnout
yeah I actually think this is a
byproduct of of all that I I'm one of
these 19 million Americans and this is
basically why if you recall
April of 20 they push back the tax
deadline to I don't remember when it was
and then so everything got pushed back
pushed back pushed back so that if your
20 got pushed back you're 21 will get
pushed back so that's essentially what's
happening right now it's like all right
I'll just deal with it later there's no
uh there's no urgency to get that done
and they kept pushing it back just like
student loan payments the exact same
thing for Barons forbearance don't keep
pushing it back
um you know this in any type of sale
there's two things that create a sale
it's urgency and scarcity if you don't
have to do it or if it's not running out
uh you don't you just won't do it so I
just don't think there's been any sense
of urgency or scarcity
um to get this done that's just my two
cents yeah but I mean every year is the
same when it comes down to that
yes but not since covid because they
kept pushing back the deadlines God if
you're saying hey the homework's due uh
on Friday well it's actually due next
month it's fine all right when are you
gonna do your homework you're not gonna
do it this Friday all right actually by
the way we're gonna actually you have to
the end of the year to do your homework
you're never gonna do your homework use
the word he didn't use the word fickle
but it was a word like fickle there's a
lot of things going on the market right
now where it's tough to kind of predict
what's going to be happening here's
another one from Yahoo money yesterday
inflation grocery prices in August Rose
13 and a half percent the highest
increase since March of 79. that's not a
small number by the way 13 and a half
percent
you know that means if you spent I don't
know a thousand dollars a month on
grocery for your family you got you got
family of five four husband wife two
kids
now you're doing 13.50 that's a hundred
and thirteen dollars 113 of after tax
money is like 200 of pre-tax money did
people get a 200 raise that people get a
13 and a half percent raise
I don't know so so too many of these
figures adding up you know it's it's
making you
kind of a and by the way did you see the
other article about real estate property
around the world how it's just dipping
did you see the chart that they had I
sent it to you on Instagram if you pull
it up
um it's not that one it's the other one
if you go on Instagram you'll see it uh
yeah that's the one you can zoom in in
that one go ahead and zoom in on that
one you can't zoom in zoom in zoom in
look at that right there go a little
lower Bloomberg go a little lower the
other way the other way the other way
yeah so there you go so the world's
hottest housing markets are facing a
painful reset okay Toronto's going up
that's not really taking a hit it's
shown from 2020 how much it's gone up
look at the number by the way Toronto's
gone up 45 just in two years 45
Stockholm went up 35 and then it's
dropped down to 20 percent Auckland went
up 45 and it's dropped to 20 so it's
dropped another 25 in the last six
months or 10 months and Sydney went up
25 and it's now only up 15 so
a a lot of people right now do you have
any opinions on the on the real estate
market are you kind of you know you have
any ideas of what you think is going to
happen with all the inventory the rates
going up how it's going to affect it
well you know back to the previous slide
on the groceries I mean you just got to
look what people are doing and credit
cards are blooming you know they're
maxed out right now savings accounts for
plummeting people are borrowing money to
grow the groceries so that's a pretty
good uh indicator that the party's over
you know get out of the pool we're
getting ready to wake up to reality
um my biggest concern through all this
is is inflation yes but deflation of
real estate when you've got houses that
you're paying 254 and you've only had
250 000 and you had to put 20 grand down
and then all of a sudden that house is
worth 180 and people just leave us with
the keys the the deflation thing could
happen with housing and that that would
be back to Euro 708 bust so you think
that's it's possible okay so if that
does happen
you know 31 is not going to be the
lowest for Dao you could be you think
we'll touch 25. the interview I gave
14 months ago 30 months ago hey you know
the the game changer here is if they
raise interest rates
guy kind of looked at me like that's
crazy I said start raising interest
rates from you know zero or one or
whatever it was now now what's a six
year six percent on a 30 year mortgage
hey keep that up
yeah 31 could be a nice number on the
Dow 31 could be a nice number if they
keep raising interest rates I want to
ask you a question since we're going in
this deep Finance Rabbit Hole I want to
ask you a question on asset allocation
um
you're a billionaire worth a billion
dollars of respect
um
without getting in the nitty-gritty what
percentage are you cash
stock
real estate
crypto other type of Investments uh
would you be willing to kind of give us
the asset allocation balance
I think the key with the asset
allocation is what makes you comfortable
you know we'll just start with let's
take a hundred thousand dollars
some people made 100 000 cash I've
literally have people that are buying
bonds I'm like bonds really you've been
Bond bonds right
um you know
um some people have 30 40 in Precious
Metals I'm like you know if they blow it
up Gold's not gonna double or triple
it's going to quadruple you don't need
30 of your portfolio but I think it
depends on
um you know the persons what makes them
comfortable really I mean some people
are are worth 10 million dollars and
they live in a 500 000 house some people
were 10 million they live in a 20
million dollar house that's what makes
them comfortable but the one thing I've
learned I have three kids
and you know when you talk about the
kind of wealth we're talking about it
distorts reality it really does and it
can mess their head up and it has that
and uh like for all of us the one thing
I've learned with kids is dividend
stocks teach them how much a million
dollars is
so if if the child does have a million
dollars in its trust that's 50 Grand a
year they need to understand that's what
a million dollars it's 50 000 bucks a
year that's what it is it's not more no
less and that's the one thing that I've
been able to do that whether they start
off with a hundred grand or 20 grand you
know 20 grand a year 20 000 in the bank
is a thousand bucks a year that's what
it is you know you know if you get up to
2 million that's 100 000 years so it
does teach the kids the value that's one
thing it's the only thing mechanisms
because they go well what's five man
what's do you know they think like that
it's like I have man don't even you know
uh I haven't given 100 Mil I haven't
given any of the kids any anything close
to five million or even three million
dollars I have one daughter that's 38.
another one's 36 my son's 24. until they
show me they can manage the money and if
you feel bad because you want somebody
to come along that kind of respects what
you've done or at least appreciates it
and at least it's going to guard it but
I was watching the Vanderbilt
um Cornelius Vanderbilt he had 10 10
kids and left 95 a percent of it I think
to William now the other uh nine kids
could handle the wealth you need to tell
William keep the wealth well so you know
even out of 10 kids he only had one that
could handle at the time this was 87
1787 he had 100 100 million which was by
the way 1 24th of the GDP I mean the the
GDP in 1887 was like 2.8 billion and he
had 100 million of it one so one out of
one out of every 28 was his in the
marriage translated into today's money
the GDP today is what
124 trillion so let's let's just say a
trillion it's a trillion he's a
trillionaire he's worth more than all
the five other guys are Vanderbilt yeah
Diane and then he did ships and and uh
trains he was he was he said your kids
are 38 36 24 or 24. you started Young
yeah
um what do your kids do now
my youngest likes computer he likes
gaming the 24 year old he loves the
gaming you know did he go to college
went to college didn't finish college he
doesn't like college didn't like books
uh Danielle so now he's just does he
have a job yeah he works for panda up in
Detroit okay yeah game doing gaming he
likes gaming likes of content yeah my um
middle daughter is an entrepreneur she
likes uh Urban products out of Utah
and then my oldest daughter is an
attorney criminal attorney and a hard
worker loves the criminal law loves
getting people out of binds when they've
done
bad things and and self-sustain they all
work they don't yeah they all work okay
but
um they don't know how to manage
sure don't know how to manage five
million dollars much less 500 million
dollars yet it's early
you believe in a whole concept that if
you pass away you give all of them you
know a third or third or third you leave
it to them or you believe more in the
you know some Jay Paul Getty he was died
very rich but he only left his five kids
a million a pop I think that's the
number what's your philosophy on that
I'm somewhere between a third or third
or third and zero zero zero
I want to see some you don't want to
give it away I want to see some
demonstration that they respect and can
handle the wealth are going to do good
deeds with it otherwise I'll find
somebody else to give it to you what
would you like let's say your kids don't
get any hypothetical where would the
money go there's so many books out there
that will tell you that all these trust
or scams I mean these universities
I mean you leave it to University I mean
they'll really all the universities are
run by the left
but um
I'd probably lean towards a private park
and then I didn't endow it to where they
you know they keep the park up
um and um just tied up so tight that
they can't rip off the truss for it Papa
John's Park and kids get free pizza
every Friday like back in the elementary
school we've built two parks we built
Ford's Fork out of Louisville and we've
got a park in Anchorage and that's
probably out of all the things I've done
that's the funds of the parks I built
yeah by the way a quick update just so
you guys know it was 3 23 when they
called this 353 it's been 30 minutes no
one's here yet what's about the timeline
of on one day deliver is it
um you want to get there in 30 minutes
okay so none of them have hit it yet
okay yeah I'll tell you what okay if you
were still CEO of Papa John's we'd have
that pizza by now
be soaked garlic sauce at this point
here now okay let's take a camera shoot
a family in the living room and then
order pizza okay 30 minutes somebody
asked where's the pizza 30 minutes every
single time
40 41 minutes they ask again
at 44 minutes people start to get pissed
off
at 54 minutes what do you think they do
at 54 minutes they're calling the store
they rounded up tonight it's been an
hour not really an hour it's 54 minutes
but they rounded up tonight oh hell yeah
so we're getting hungry we're now
between
a little bit of agitation to move into
barometer over to super pissed off so
let's see how they do I love how you
know the metrics and and just the that's
his business of course
I mean can you give a little insight
when you he walked in and by the way
thank you you brought some pizza for the
production team they were they were very
appreciative he brought the pizza yeah I
believe so we ordered the pizza yeah by
the way you know what is cool just so
you know for the folks at Papa John's if
you're pissed off
he brought Papa John's Pizza and he
brought Just Pizza so it's not like he
didn't bring even though he's calling
you out he still brought a bunches but
what he did out there was super
impressive I'll give you the mic right
now but he went in opened the box
everyone at the valuetainment got a
master class in Pizza 101 you see here
right here Crossings at this all right
the sauce all right but give us a little
like your mindset when you saw this
pizza well I've been Consulting Jeff's
now for three years and Jets Pizza never
left the quality and they never left
their mission you know they suck to
their knitting and then they're people
in their Papa John's I've been on their
case now for three years that hey you
better stop playing games with your food
quality and service you better make it
the way the pizza was designed to make
it you're gonna get yourself in trouble
and both things have come to fruition
but I wanted to see Papa John's next to
Jets because it really is reality they
didn't know who was ordering it and two
is if you watch the people and you don't
make that Papa John's is a really good
pizza if you make it right yeah but if
you don't have the right ingredients
start slipping on those ingredients and
you don't put it together right it's a
mediocre product I'll bet you go out
there the Jet's Pizza is probably eaten
and they probably haven't eaten the
puppy I don't want to offend you man I
saw the pizza popped I didn't realize
how you were at I saw the Jets Pizza and
the Papa John's I took a slice of the
Jets of course you did it was crossover
as the name changed who's first who's
first first
Pizza Hut was first okay Pizza Hut's
first place
[Music]
three no it's not you can't say 358 it's
56
355. so they got here in 22 minutes
okay set it up right in front of him
because he's the expert here I thought
we were like a blind taste test no we're
not gonna
okay so we got Pizza Hut there nobody
else is Syria Natalia okay all right so
Natalia I vote for you to be the pizza
gal you keep coming in and parade the
pizza it's our Vanna White over here on
Pizza okay so we got Pizza Hut took 32
minutes
uh is what it took so by the way is it
fair to say that Papa John's should
change the name to decent ingredient
decent Pizza Papa John's instead of
better ingredient better Pizza by the
way how did you come up with the name
Papa John you were you were a kid at the
time okay I'm um I got the recipes
worked at Rocky's worked at Greeks had
the equipment and got all this in my
brain and what's going to make a
pizzeria yeah didn't have a name I'm in
La folla door in 1982. there's a door
made uh made of mine marketing major
from Chicago I said I got everything but
I don't have a name he comes back three
days later with the logo in the name
Papa John's straight that was it dorm
mate from LaFollette gym 1982 Ball State
so you never picked it you didn't pick
you didn't pick the name that was a
buddy you lived within the door yeah
thanks homie I said if it ever goes big
I'll give you a pizza a week for the
rest of your life he's never come
forward
now if I was back in Papa John's I would
put out a 10 million reward maybe not 10
minutes let's do 500 000. whatever man
what something rewarding no no no I like
that yeah we're gonna find this guy that
sounds good to me who came up to her
name Papa John's it was you don't even
remember his name no he was a friend he
was a dorm mate but you don't remember
his name you don't remember like your
roommate's name that had the front yeah
Adam he didn't like school he just said
it so that's true he's busy there you go
Erica's 24 year old son I relate to that
son okay so Pizza Hut's first is are you
surprised that Pizza Hut's first or no I
mean it's hit and miss in different
markets can we get some plates my
concern with
um the big players Papa John's Domino's
and uh Little Caesars is the when you
really don't put it together right and
you have the right ingredient all you've
done is create a commodity
and when you're a commodity then you're
chasing the Rat Hole down the drain of
price and that's what you've got so
right now you know Papa John's scores
are at parity with Little Caesars on the
acsi award Papa John's scores are like
75-74 the last two years Little Caesar
scores are like 70 so Papa John's is
that parody so you're going to say
better ingredient better Pizza turn
around and sell a product that we saw
out front and then the consumer
perceives you as a Little Caesar's
quality they're in a bad it's a death
spiral it's a black cloud they better
get it they better get their acting and
then get back to the the product that
made that brand great but Little Caesars
I feel is by far and away the cheapest
they have the full five dollars hot and
ready they are playing in a market like
untouched how's that look by the way
this is
this is actually remember the two things
you got to have ingredients in every
bite ingredients out to the edge now
you've got an inch pretty well around
that most of it that's a No-No but we on
that Papa John Pizza we saw earlier was
you know two three four inches in the
Jets it was right to the edge so let's
see how the other guys do but I
um not the pepperoni yeah this is a this
is a frozen crust this isn't a homemade
crust but this is Leprino cheese which
it's cheap it's about as cheap as you
can get uh pepperonis look okay but I
mean I mean it's Pizza why would you
order that over frozen pizza I mean
there's nothing about that that's
spectacular why don't you order that
Pizza Hut over frozen pizza why would
you look at that I mean tell me why
that's better than frozen pizza do you
want to take a bite we're going to take
a bite we got now we got what we got
next who's next
all right Papa John Big Papa John so
Papa John what was the time what time
did it get here just two seconds ago two
seconds ago so 423 37 minutes
have an issue that
um it didn't deliver in this area hold
on Natalia
oh so the issue that they didn't deliver
to this area so we had to call another
one God so that took another two or
three minutes I got you okay all right
cool so we got Papa John's how does that
look to you when you see that these are
better than the ones we order right off
the bat
um but here's the here Eric you want to
grab the mic so you can zoom in because
folks if you're watching this right now
let me tell you this place smells like
pizza and it smells incredible believe
me Eric wants to grab more than the bike
he wants one of these guys
so what what if you look at the Papa
John's versus the pizza you can't really
tell the difference
um if they were uh right if they weren't
right next to each other you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference and the the
Papa John's has got a couple sins first
of all you got the copies falling over
the heads so the reason we created the
uh crust we we called it Edge stretching
is so the crust will be able to dip it
in the garlic sauce you've pretty well
lost that
um luxury when you've covered it up it
does have plenty of pepperonis on it
looks like it's got plenty of cheese uh
you got an inconsistent bake but again
the the thing that makes Papa John's
Papa John's is a crust and we've gone
from a hand tossed dough to where they
now do it with the machine so they
actually plant in a you know like a
padding place it down and so you lose
that authentic really where the dough
kind of Rises but this is this still
wouldn't be an eight Pizza this would be
probably a seven pizza maybe seven out
of ten you're saying seven out of ten if
it's not an eight you're not supposed to
serve it
um this product
would be it wouldn't be an eight either
but at least it's got toppings on it but
again you'll see there's not toppings
out to the edge but if I'd have been CEO
and these were to come this would have
been a huge disappointment these would
have been sub seven pizzas uh today
they're probably what I've seen in Papa
John's the last you know 16 months these
are actually some of the better ones
I've seen but again they're not you're
not going to be able to differentiate
between a pizza and a Papa John's but
let's see what the other two players
come in what about the uh The Works uh
Pizza Hut one down over there by the way
you're not gonna stop Pat from having
some of that garlic sauce right there I
already know where Pat's at for parent
like my eyes on the ground are there
onions on this pizza yeah are there
onions on the pat we're gonna have an
issue with this or John for John but by
the way so you look at that and you look
at this now some people like thin crust
but what do you think about the way the
Pizza Hut one looks I think this is I
think the Papa John's in this case is
demonstrably better
um the cheese is more moist because you
got more toppings this pizza doesn't
have much on it considering it's
supposed to be a works that doesn't work
yeah when you don't put as much on it
dries out so whereas Z2 these two
peaches are pretty well at parity
I'd say Papa John's is going to be a
little bit better than the pizza because
it's got slightly more cheese on it
um and they're prepared about the same
level uh I'd say the pizza pizza is not
nearly as good as the Papa John work
Pizza in this case so Papa John beats
pizza here don't know in this particular
uh one case one survey doesn't make a
study you know but but the fact that
you're being straight up though listen
so so Pizza against Papa John's on the
works
Papa John's is winning so far but
remember this is this is the worst Pizza
it's about the worst standard you can
have Pizza Hut is the worst standard the
vet one of the best Brands it was but
now their their product quality has gone
down actually more than Papa John's has
gone down so this this is the horse race
to the bottom
horse race to the bottom bottom between
these two players what's their incentive
for going down to the bottom to cut
costs labor cut what stock more money
stock options
stock options I mean bureaucrats all
the CEO Rob Lynch and this board care
about is the share price
what they don't understand is you keep
doing this and you're going to be you're
going to be at 10 a share they cannot
keep Papa John's cannot keep doing this
and and expect to be it I think it's I
think 85 bucks a shirt should be free
I'd shorted I think it's a 60 70 bucks I
think in the stock tip it's a 60 70
stock and then I would look at it real
hard to make sure they got their act
together
tell me one good thing that's happened
since I left at that company
Internationals down the tubes
transactions traffic are down the tubes
qualities down the tube they've lost
best place to work they've lost the acsi
service thinks image think tell me one
good things has happened to that company
since I left stocks less than when I
left six years ago
who's the spokesperson not for them
out there doing his thing
I like he's got a great Qs score two
score he does have a great skew score I
think he's a good Ambassador if the
product's good I think he now is putting
his name on a bad problem yeah like he
this new Shack bowl that came out yeah
the Shaq Pizza bow that's got more bad
product uh for reviews more people have
been on the uh the shack Bowl than any
product they've ever put out they've got
more negative I don't think Shaquille is
going to continue to put his name on you
don't think I don't think he's going to
continue to put his name on a fair
product wow okay I mean that's a that's
not good for papa John if that happens
by the way just everybody heard his
score just so you know
Pizza Hut 32 minutes so fastest not the
best quality but definitely fastest Papa
John 37 minutes like they didn't cut
this pizza
didn't cut the pizza didn't cut the
pizza
if you're listening can we get some
napkins
what do you mean they didn't cut the
pizza they didn't cut the pizza yeah
I just roll it over lazy so lazy cut I
got it
I got it who were the other two that
were waiting for
Dominoes Dominoes Dominoes on Jets yep
hold on okay we got this right here
that's another thing I think they've
done I think they've changed the they've
definitely changed the crust but it
doesn't taste the same
I don't know if they change the sauce
but something something with the product
doesn't taste I got to tell you I feel
like we got to do something for our
audience out there we got to do some
sort of pull some sort of some sort of
Lottery here so we send them some pizza
or something I feel like we got to do
this for the people I don't know Pat I'm
just
I'm really concerned doctor 23. it's
been 43 minutes it's been 43 minutes
well Domino's when I grew up if it was a
half hour or less
I would like to know what the audience
either favored Pizza who they go to did
we do a poll I'd love to send some pizza
to someone out there I don't know Pat
you're the boss here I'm just I only
work here I only make the pizza here
you're gonna send it to me it's gonna be
with their local come by we'll get oh
what do you mean we can send it
okay so uh are you impressed or no the
one from Papa John's doesn't taste like
the Original Pizza they've changed the
recipe they've done something I don't
know exactly what they've done I know
they changed the dough recipe so they
could make it softer to spin it out with
a machine but that doesn't taste like
our sauce
so I don't know if they they went to a
paste sauce or if they put something
else in there but it does not taste like
the original recipe in my opinion
this actually
these two are parody with taste you know
just a question of you know they taste a
little bit different but not that much
but you know that zingy sweet sauce that
always made Papa John Papa John's
um do you know what I'm talking about
yeah of course yeah yeah I'll let you
try I'm gonna try
let me ask you Papa John's used to have
the garlic sauce but then there was like
a cheese sauce at some point wasn't
there another sauce here we have both
okay so this one's Papa John's
a cup or no
not really let's see who's not real
somebody's coming in so Domino's yeah
they won't deliver what do you mean
that don't go and deliver when's the
last time what do you mean Pizza
with Papa John's none of the dominoes
that are in our vicinity
wait what the audience has none of the
three dominoes in the area refused so
which dominoes What cities were these in
The Dominoes you called well you said
Vero Beach
I'll lower him a little bit guys he's a
little too loud uh but yeah we called
three in a proximity of our area none of
them offer delivery to our address we
even went online to double check and
they won't how far how far was that
three miles yeah there's one there's one
literally nine minutes down the road and
they said they don't deliver well not
deliver well Domino's this is not good
for you so what you just did you just
We're not gonna be able to get a chance
to maybe that's a good thing by the way
John I don't want to offend you you are
absolutely right this is it's hard to
even get the slice out over here it's
falling apart it was not cut well I
don't know does it not happen after Papa
John's well that's why you got to
measure what they're doing because they
won't they won't cut it they won't bake
it and then what was the franchisees I
love them to death but
um
you know you're talking about successful
entrepreneurs they don't whine
franchisees they complain but they'll
make the product wrong cook it wrong cut
it wrong and then blame it on a
marketing or blame it on technology but
I mean it's unbelievable you've got to
measure what the franchise is doing
because if you're not weighing them
every day and making sure they're on
their game they'll slouch so what do you
think about Jet's Pizza that just came
in it's still a little hot
you want some Jets
hmm
first time we're eating something on a
podcast
Pat how are you feeling about the sauce
to me I'm heaven on Earth but he's the
expert
I want to see what Pizza Hut is no this
ain't doing it for me
it's not doing it which one is it this
was the Papa John's this is not the Papa
John's I'm used to
I don't I don't know what they've
changed something's different
straight up
when you got a winner I don't know why
you change it which one's Jets who's
your jets okay let me see the Jets works
just grab a slice for me I'm all good I
was in the military so just grab me a
slice
Rob Gargiulo can you grab us some
napkins buddy all right
oh interesting so different uh
very different
Adam yes sir
thanks pbd bye
works let's see here
jet is super hot
it's hotter because it's real that's
they make their dough in the store
I think Pizza Hut is a frozen dough
Papa John's has got the machine pressing
and out and then also Jets that's fresh
pack sauce that's why it's a little bit
more robust
I think jet sauce is really good I don't
think it's as good as Papa John's when
Papa John's is Papa John's but
that didn't taste like Papa John's to me
um
this place smells like pizza Kai grab a
slice guy I'm waiting for the pepperoni
over there come grab a slice come on
come home everybody Natalia everybody
wants you to grab a slice for whatever
reason in the comment section
here's what I think I think if the Papa
John Pizza was made the way it was
supposed to be made with the ingredients
that it's supposed to be made with
I think it would hands down it would
kill the pizza that's uh
pizza and my gut is
Jets P round Pizza is not as good as
it's pan but Papa John's Round Pizza is
better than just pan pizza round pizza
but
in this case Jets is better because
they're not they're not making the right
or they stop doing something maybe
differently
um but I think that Papa John Pizza was
made the way we used to make it it would
it would clean this Jet's Pizza's clock
it's not made the way it used to be made
so I think this is a little bit better
um the Pizza Works there's nothing on it
it's dry it's no good
I think the Papa John works is
definitely better
um than the Pizza Hut and then I think
the the Jets has a little bit more
toppings
and um a little bit more uh wholesome
I'd say it's slightly better than the
Papa John's because they change the
crust they change the sauce but
um I'd give Jets
um adjust number one I give Papa John's
to
um on the on the works and I give Papa
John's and pizza the two on the
pepperoni
and um and then I get pizza at a third
on the Works pizza you you so for me
works is last
you know we pass over that Pizza Hut
pepperoni so we could hand it over this
way and get it to Kai
thank you sir
the best slice I've had
so far was the original slice that we
had out there from that was was that
Jets as well that the pan the yes that
was awesome jets has a fantastic uh pan
pizza
we got the round Pizza I don't think the
round Pizza is as good as Papa John's
when Papa John's is made right in this
case Papa John's were made right so I
think the Jets is a little better
okay all right well listen Domino's you
had a chance so here's what we learned
speed is the fastest Pizza Hut one 32
minutes Papa John's was 37 minutes
um jets was third
and then dominoes we call three
different places they don't deliver even
though the closest one is three miles
away what's the criteria of how close is
it like uh do you give it to somebody
and then somebody else cannot have a
Papa John's within a 10 mile radius
what's the structure yeah great question
we do a seven mile uh delivery time
seven months seven minutes we like go
seven eight minutes so you do it by
Drive times so you may have downtown New
York where
you literally can drive five minutes and
you have three main people or you may go
in you know Bedford Indiana and you may
be able to go 10 miles in 10 minutes but
it's a it's a population
um drive time equation that you look at
not miles totally makes sense when
somebody orders a pizza how quickly is
it made and how long is it is it like
too long to be sitting there
yeah
when you're running the Papa John's
store
everything's six minute intervals you
want a made in six minutes
you want baked in six minutes and you
went out the door in six minutes sure
and you know try to get to the door in
six minutes plus the delivery time so
anyway a little cushion there you're 30
minutes
so it's a lifestyle and a mindset and a
game of six seven minutes
six six six six six six
the devil interesting
and if you were to make a pizza and you
can pick between what's most important
the dough the sauce or the like the
toppings where if you had to have one of
them needs to be grade A and then like
secondary and then third what would be
the most important in order to like save
the taste of the pizza as much as
possible forty percent of your flavor
comes from the tomato sauce your your
cheese is really like a copper wire it's
a conductor it's just a medium to for
the flavor to to kind of go through
um and to talk out of both sides of my
mouth the dough is really the key so I
have a a
actually a pizza stone in my backyard a
pizza oven gets up to six seven hundred
degrees
um and what I'll do is I'll go get dough
from Papa John's dough from Jets and
then sauce from each of them into this
play
but I think the Jets Pandora with Papa
John's sauce and then this this pizza
that you just saw Jets that's Grande
this is Grande Cheese
it's a it's a thicker chewier cheese
this is going to be
280 a pound
whereas Papa John cheese is going to be
a dollar eighty a pound this is loprino
this is a lot cheaper so if I could have
a combination if I could have Jets Pando
Papa John sauce and a combination of
fabrino cheese with a little Grande
cheese ah you're home perfect start a
business what are the chances what are
the chances
Papa John's franchisees and board is
watching this last part of the clip
and they're sitting there saying guys
did you hear what Bobby what he said he
said we recommended this what are the
chances they're gonna actually implement
the recommendation you're given the 280
cheese the sauce what's the chances
I wrote the book on how to do there's a
book it's called Papa and they can't
even read the book you know I can tell
you what they they can't I mean they
can't you could how do you get healthy
you eat right and you exercise but they
don't do it it would take where's that
Papa John Pizza at it would take
it would take
12 to 16 months
are going back in and keeping my
hand on their shoulder in 12 to 18
months to get them back you don't when
you're selling a million pizzas a day
and you got 5 000 stores and they're all
over they're just out of shape the the
amount of fortitude and exertion and
energy on my part to get them back in
shape would take a year every day on
their case no no I don't hear about
marketing I don't know about technology
I want to know why you're why we're not
making the product the way it's supposed
to be made the pizza the pizza it's it's
my Farmer Friend Sells at Modesto it's
the food stupid
economy stupid there's a lot of them can
I just give a quick shout out this kid
over here this guy Kai by the way he
hasn't been on the podcast in
you know we love this guy this guy every
weekend he makes his own pizza that's
his thing for years now no it's been a
lot of years your permission to speak
now go ahead what you got no I though
from scratch everything so it's been uh
it's been fun
well I've got uh I've got a pizza oven
in my house in Kentucky The Columns will
hold up are 1700 years old back to the
emperor Constantine out of the Roman
Empire that's great so anytime you guys
want to come and you when you all come
see me in Kentucky bring Kai and we'll
make pizza
you can feel it you can film your show
listen you can film your show from uh
the back my backyard and have the time
of your life make a pizza with all due
respect uh I'm gonna let them go to
Kentucky I was recently invited to uh
Eastern Europe with Andrew Tate to go
visit him in Romania so after that trip
I'll maybe I'll come to Kentucky but
that's first on my list so I can go get
some pizza with those guys Kentucky I
lived in Kentucky two years so I I I
would actually entertained I thought
that'd be great thank you for the invite
uh appreciate you for coming out uh uh
this was great this is the first time
we've done uh something like this and
this decision was made last second by
the way yep I walked in I see him all
the order and pizza I'm like are you
okay if we ordered he was you know
enough of a sport to do this and uh once
again thanks for coming out thanks for
for sharing your story any crazy
projects you're working on right now you
haven't found that business yet we're
working on Papa's Farms okay um organic
farm no fertilizers no chemicals a
little beehives and and bee farms so
we're having some fun with Papa Farms
doing a lot of things on nutrition just
got involved with a company called wild
Health which is genomics testing your
DNA but having a lot of fun in the
health field but I'll come back on when
I get something that I really can get my
teeth into and share with you but I
appreciate y'all having you look great
man I got to tell you I'm seriously I
saw you I was like oh I hope he's doing
okay I didn't know what to expect he
walked in I was like holy he said should
I put a jacket on I said
Thank you so once again thanks for
coming out again I hope you enjoyed it
as much as we did give it a thumbs up
and subscribe if you did and tune in
again tomorrow we have another show
coming for you tomorrow take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye thank
you Papa John